with those seven consecutive quality
starts has the best dra of any rocky
starter at four zero six he pitches well
here at coors field 24 and 12 all time
which is second best in club history
and that's a beautiful slider with depth
sends attella pound in the zone and he
strikes out the great mookie bets one
god
in the air to left field but lots of
room for ryan valade and he makes his
first put out as a rocky at coors field
for out number two here in the top of
the first and turn her on the ground
right to krone he'll run to the bag and
that is a marvelous start
[Applause]
the dodgers since moving to la have had
three guys lead the majors in wins
drysdale did it once kershaw's done it
twice
sandy koufax did it three times and
julio is a couple weeks away from
joining that
list that's a fly ball to center field
that sends betts back
with room for a deep out number one
[Applause]
bounce to short for seeger
get those sleeves out on this cool night
in denver henria says the first two outs
on four pitches
that one spins up there gets popped sky
high in the mile high city
turner makes the catch and on six
pitches ureas with a clean first
well boogie bets it's round two for the
dodgers against sensitive he's in the
air to charlie and right
well you know you have good stuff when
you're ahead of a hitter like mookie
betts 3-1 and you can still jam him with
the fastball
off speed roll over two outs
he's got it working tonight doesn't he
swinging a grounder over the mount
charged by story bare hands but he won't
have a play
just not hit hard enough and trey turner
with terrific speed able to beat that
out that's the first hit and the first
base runner for either team coming with
two outs in the fourth
not going and it's tapped
toward mcmahon and he'll throw out
muncie no problem after the infield hit
so round two now for the rockies
against urias and this is bounced to
second slowly and
hanson will reach
trey turner because of the speed
never got it out of his glove
box left side the only play is at first
for justin trying to get rogers
played by monsieur stepping into the
baseline to catch it
story digs it out flies it into the left
field corner from gavin lux he's got it
story's out number two
charlie blackmon to see what he can do
with hampson down at second in a
scoreless game in the fourth
this ball is driven to right center
field this will get down and they'll hit
off the wall blackman has extra bases
what nothing colorado
and the rockies break the ice in the
fourth it's one to nothing
charlie's at good history against julio
urias and we've talked throughout
blackman's long career with the rockies
his ability to hit left-handed pitching
as a left-handed batter
so blackman now at second with two outs
for cj crone crone that's a fair ball
the rockies are going to take a
two-nothing lead
crone headed towards second blackman
scores
got to love those two out rallies in
loto rockies go back to back with
doubles to score twice krone's 25th
double
and 84th rbi
rockies for the first two runs of the
day on to the fifth
2-2 swung on and missed
strike three on smith
one two three
and then rox grounds the base hit the
other way first hit to leave the infield
for the dodgers and this fifth inning
kept the lot 2-2 pitch
raley
lux is headed for third he'll get there
without a throw and back to back two out
hits for the dodgers couple two out two
strike hits and it's
ground ball bases in right field urea
strives in the first dodger run of the
game and with three consecutive two out
hits it's 2-1 breaking ball but he shows
his eye hand coordination right here
fooled on the pitch but boy did he do a
nice job just trying to make contact
give himself a chance release the top
hand extend the swing through the ball
find the hole and cut the lead in half
three straight two out hits three
straight two strike kids
baltimore chop this is no play and this
is a tie game
four straight two out two strike hits
and it's tied at two
trey turner an infield single in two
tries leads it off
trey turner smacks the first pitch of
the sixth into right base hit dodgers
gunning for their first lead max muncie
waits
driven to left center field way back
though
muncie into second with a double
turner's headed home he'll score the
dodgers take the lead
first lead of the night for the dodgers
as muncie cranks a double the other way
trey turner builds up so much speed when
he comes home to slide it's like he's
just gliding on ice
served into right blackman's there
huntsey send it for third the throw is
not in time
man in third with one away for will
smith
smith goes the other way with a deep fly
ball blackman to the corner running down
but that'll bring in max muncie
dodgers four rockies two they get two in
the fifth and now two in the six
[Music]
[Applause]
gave up the two runs in the fourth
pitched around a lead off doubled in the
fifth and now pitches with the lead for
the first time tonight
gives up a leadoff hit here
the other way from rogers
so here's crone an rbi double in the
fourth two outs rogers at second this
ball line to right center field this
will get the job done
coming home is rogers crow digging
towards second and he's in with another
double
make it four to three
has 26 doubles now on the season for cj
another off speed pitch spilly and uh he
reacted well to it elias diaz who's due
against durias he's won for 14 lifetimes
this is down the left field line this is
a long run for lux
he didn't make the catch he came out of
his glove crown scores diaz to second
we're all tied up it's tied here in
colorado 4-4 between the dodgers and the
rockies and we're two gone
in the seventh inning blake trining
comes on for charlie blackman
he struck him out with the high fastball
trining gets out of the jam the game
stays tied at four
tie game at home you get your closure
typically and carlos estevez is out
there for buddy black
and this is to shallow right and charlie
lays out makes the catch
charlie blackman has been covering some
ground in right field looked like he was
going to pull up for a moment but
stuck that glove out and then grabbed it
looked like the back of his leg what a
grab by charlie out number one
smith ground ball to
short they get smith for the second half
and the ricochet a chance to get
scott
on the pitch back
he threw an absolute missile to second
and the rockies get luxe
we go to the bottom of the night 4-4
here in the bottom of the ninth and sam
hilliard
who singled off the bench in the seventh
and stayed in and left field will have
the first crack at jansen
ball four
winning run
with big time wheels to first that's a
good start he strikes out hampton
one man out flies it to center field but
routine for mookie betts and there's out
number two
get in the air right field
and this game goes to the 10th
rocky's going to extra innings for the
14th time for their announce pujol says
the pink shader
basic center field
gavin luck's trucks home albert pujols a
pin [ __ ] rbi single giving the dodgers
the 5-4 lead they brought him to la for
just that situation right there
line drive caught throw to first double
play
well pitcher riding at first gotham
didn't get back so to the bottom of the
10th and it will be bruce star grader
all
got him
good slider from gradual for the first
out of the 10th
here comes rooster with a 100-mile power
fastball that's grounded a second for
trey turner and they're an out away
time run at third now winning run at
first
fly ball center field no big deal mookie
bucks the dodgers win it and 10. dodgers
five rockies four and it's down to a
half game
you